the name patricio el boca I am received
from the jacket and the information for 16
years more or less
currently I work as that
software resort in tato pian which is a company
that is a spin-off of the open where the
foundation has a global organization and
works  for the opening of information and
open data I am a member of open data
córdoba before all that I worked for several
years as outgoing data I already finished data
analysis depending on the time of
year
before that we were brother students
or philosopher seriously I studied philosophy
so I am good  a potpourri of
quite strange things well the objective of this
talk is I think that these objectives
the first is to make a
general introduction to the little exploited and with a lot of
potential the open data ecosystem of
the world it seems to me that to
make a conference of a programming language
that you  you go with data to
show this ecosystem and this world and
this universe that is open data
seems extremely important to me  before in the
second objective it is good python is at
the heart of the world's open data
either in infrastructure or in the
tools we use to
explore open data so it
seems to me that here we have enormous potential
to enter the world of
open data now  for the very fact of
knowing python and the second objective I
have is to watch these conferences a little bit.
I love coming
because I can see how large companies
like mercadolibre like spotify like
google can use these techniques
in their day to day but it is also
true that  there is a reality that with
the tools that we have
we can do small projects that have a
lot of impact in other areas
that are not big big
research I love coming here to
conferences I learn a lot but
it is also true that there are problems in
the world that are being solved  and something that
happens to me that when I started to
work and started to study  So
a few years ago the
conference came and came out with a bunch of
tools, I picked it up and said well
that's all then it gave way to
go from what I learned to solving a
problem or a project didn't have a
problem but after a project it was
like  medium if not
especially for those who are thinking
I think that the second objective I have
with this talk is to show you
that there are a lot of things that can be
done with what you learn here
that there is no need to wait around for
a large company enters to do
work with data and not only
that but also with the
open data ecosystem that we have we can
start working at home
to generate our own portfolio
our own show that is to be able to
say the company look I have  experience
look at all the things i did today there was
a morning talk where the
guys were talking about how good they
wanted to do this job for
extract texts to extract sentences
information from the texts and how it came
getting a cup of tea so
well it's a problem where I
got data to do my work
well a little bit the objective is not to
throw the pitch with this talk for
people who are just starting  is there is
an ecosystem and a large universe of
opportunities and problems to solve
and raw material that is
open data that we can use to do
a lot of things
and the end of all this talk has a
little that is open data and its
huge ecosystem  And they also know how
we can apply a little bit of the
tools that we learn here
to solve some social problem,
especially social. I speak because
the open data system is usually open data
on the most social
and public issues
and they leave wanting to do things,
so it is  key he saw the lie
then I'm going as happy with this
talk well before I start a little  ito of
questions those who know what
open data is
those who worked with open data
you have from here they don't come from
technical
and road careers to those who come from
social careers
well let's start with open data and where to
find open data let's
start with the basic definition
so that we all understand that we
are talking about data that can be
used, reused, redistributed
freely by anyone and
that is subject at most to the
requirement of attribution and
sharing in the same way in which it
appears, that is, it is data that
is loose  on the internet and that
can be used reused and that as
much as many the only restriction
I have to use them is that well
I attribute where I got that data from and if
I share it again without modifying
anything about this mind these are
completely free data to use it
but I am going to focus on this little word
that is reused  if the objective of
open data is to be reused that
can be reused and for this it
needs to be published in a format that
can be read by a computer if
open data is data if I can
grab and write a script write a
program that consumes  that data and
automatically processes it if many
times it may be that a government
releases a pdf with a table full of
bids and bid values
but
from going to the pdf to a ccd that I can
analyze there is a whole process
of data extraction and
enormous data cleaning then ssp df although it is
public information it is not considered as
open data for the data to be
specifically open it has to be
readable by a computer that is to say it
has to be a ccd to a jason or an xml
to a tv in  sql or some format that I
can easily access, in the
open data universe a bit
of the philosophy that governments are
public is born, so as the government is
public  ico the information they handle
should be public and I as a citizen
should have the possibility of
accessing that data many come and tell me
paying utopian prices the governments
do not deliver the data well reality in
Argentina there is what they call the law of
access to information  that
establishes who information in the hands of the
state must be accessible to all
people is answered in
open formats even think that the law
specifies that all this information
should be assembled in
and published in an open format so
that people can consume it and  In addition,
this format facilitates its
circulation and redistribution, so
there is a law, as a citizen, I can
go to the government, exercise my
citizen right to say, give me this information,
and there is a law, a regulation that
obliges the state, depending on the implementing entity,
and if it is local.  and
provincial that has fifteen thousand fifteen
business days to deliver the
i  information and if I don't have a
legal recourse to be able to go and make a judgment
of the state of why it is not
giving me that information then there is
a whole regulatory boat that
allows me to access is information and
then our topic sometimes that they
don't tell you  they deliver work against a little bit of
the experience we had but there is
that regulatory framework and within the
ecosystem within the law the
implementation of this law exists or they
call it open data portals
for open theater no more than a
software a website that on the side of the
The government allows them to label,
catalog and deposit all the
information they have and on the
end user's side it allows me to browse,
search, find and download that
information
on the platform par excellence for
publishing open data
worldwide called citan and it's basically
Mayans  and all because there are other
platforms but basically all the
governments of the world use quote
behind is u  n framework
made in python imagine a
wordpress yes a wordpress you can
make a website and generate content
that are good blogs and that is like a
wordpress but instead of generating blogs and
post genres data sets information yes
then this is a payton framework
completely of its that allows me to
release to generate portals to release
information and say
the heart of the global infrastructure
under which the data is released is
made in python and that is a great goal and not
only is it a great goal but it
is also  the young xurxo, well, architecture is a
little bit when I was
talking about the talk, get involved in this
because this topic
is a talk for the conar, I pass
the time as well as the present, but
well, I wanted to comment a little bit on several
things that seem interesting to me,
great ways of  the architecture of
sicán in the first time that is
fully developed in python
this is a second school that 100%
pressures is in  git cap not only
that all the source code
of the application is on github but also in the
same cabestany kit the references to
the two weekly meetings held by the
team of technical leaders of this
platform where they define the priority
of the children the priority  of the
work roadmap where it is discussed how the architecture is going to be
generated is
mainly developed by the
community and it is something that I love,
when the sica code enters
you find some things that are
medium wide but if you understand the
context in which
an application was developed that was developed by
people in their spare time and suddenly,
well, the US government took it over
and generated its open data portal
and suddenly the rest united and london and
the jockey and austral and began to  casa
has a community of five monkeys that
never received funding and
yet the main governments of the
world are using their platform
then it started to grow
exponentially well it was all chaos
how the story
behind how this platform was created grew
it is very rich very interesting there are more
than 200 relieved stays relieved
means cadiz and it took the trouble to
enter so it changes if you look  I am
using this, it is in the web address,
but there are more than a thousand portals in the world
installed, get it and I stick to
many more, as I said recently, the USA,
London, Australia, Argentina understands with
very large systems, we are going to go into
detail about open data portals where
I can  finding information
is used by all governments and
not only governments I am a player
I am working on a project with the
bill melinda gates foundation with the
bill gates foundation which we are
implementing an
internal open data portal for them to be
used as a repository  data catalog
but still has several challenges the
second is the first is the m  migration to
payton 3
obviously python 2 expires and
support is allowed in 2020 so there is
a whole effort to migrate from what
is already in champions 2.7 to local payton 3
a double good challenge another one is
that it is made with by those who  I'm
old, they have it better than flash, but they
have a great challenge, which is to evacuate
compatibility, that is, I have to
update all my software, but at the same
time I have 150 governments in the world that
are using it before, I can't leave it
without support, I'm like the process  and the
design that was developed at the
management level so that it can be
migrated as it continues to be used the truth
is that it is a story that really deserves
a separate talk as I said in
Argentina there are more or less
70 more or less open talent
the sources someone said on twitter
I think there are 70 seems completely
reliable to me given the level of journalism in
Argentina so I said perfect but at
least the source exists and I am consistent
what a port is  Open data, as
I said, is a website. The first example that
I want to show a bit is the data.
Steal data. Government is the main
open data portal of the Argentine government
in one that brings together a lot of
information on different topics in
Argentina.  one of the
ministries has its own data
but this is the portal as the core
as the main one note that they have more
than 1000 data sets published today
so out there a claw says there was
look how cool this algorithm that
I found to train
linear regressions and open where  be with data do
to make linear relationships well here
there is martínez and carillo on the right he
says to peace and series there is a whole
page dedicated to time series from
argentina that they can use used a
lot to test those things because to
show a small landmark example that he says
there is  data on open data from the
Argentine justice portal if
justice opens data and they have a project  ecto
super interesting justice 2020 to
open data there is a gender section
that is very detailed I did not explore it
but it seems to me a super
interesting section to analyze in this
portal there is a data set on the
prison population of Argentina
where are all the prisoners  there is a
little face interested in the subject not
all the prisoners are there the reasons why they
were there if they were victims of
violence there is about torture in the
criminal case there is to make reports about the
prison overpopulation in argentina
the truth is that this portal that lays the foundation
57 back  there are extremely interesting things
the energy data portal also
the ministry of energy has an
open data portal here there is
also a super interesting rate to explore
that is basically geolocated all
the service stations in Argentina
with the price of gasoline at the pump
over time, so that
super interesting investment to
analyze that is  doing and also
many other time series
super cups to analyze
in the chamber of deputies of Argentina
also has an open data portal
here it is not there although the last
time I entered the laws were not in an
open data if there was a data
set where  there was a reference to the
laws so one can be with
csb action where is the link where you
can download the pdf with all the laws and
not only all the laws but
there is a data set here that has the
transcript of all the
deputies' sections  in which a girl from
Uruguay grabbed that data set and made a
candy they did that
great so because they did an entire
analysis on the participation of the
deputies in the sessions by gender they
also stood by gender to say
well with how much to control women
in  Congress when they speak to
men, that is why the truth is that the
amount of things that can be done
with this data is incredible, it is
only subject  to the imagination it is
very little explored and what I am going to
sing next are the
use cases that we have done and how
with little effort we can generate
a lot of impact in places of
society where our tools do not reach
well  go ahead with this slide but a
little bit of the experience here I want to
calm down a little
and tell you how good we work
in open data córdoba which is an NGO here
in córdoba that works a little bit with
open data and also
generating civic technology we work not
only in analysis  of
open data but in the development of
applications for electoral transparency
we were doing a parallel
scrutiny in the last one in the last
elections in córdoba and
we also worked hard with
journalists in data journalism trying to with
all this information and all to
generate the tool of
journalists that they can use for their
publications or help  to them among
so much tangle of data to be generated as
important data to make a
publication of proven more because
for example there is open data on a
list of all the companies and
partners that are in Argentina and that are
open in Argentina and cross that database of
data with other databases out there
gave the journalists their interest and
super interest in each journalist but
they don't know how to do it anymore they don't have the
tools and it's something we
do in a weekend so it
seems to me that there we as a community
technology we can get involved and contribute
from the short time we have to
generate a lot of
good impact some of the projects in return
showed a little bit of code that in
reality the idea is not to show
code to analyze the code but to
show that with little you can  do
interesting things a friend told me duck
stop stealing with this example because
for five years you have been stealing with this
example but hey  when I started
working and studying data science I
was looking for time series because I
was analyzing time series and
studying and I was tired
of the Australian oil production rate
than the typical and classic example I study
equality where time series can come out
so I grabbed and searched
open data I found the
vehicular flow by units of the tolls of
the Buenos Aires highway so
I said hey, how interesting is this data
set so I grabbed between the page
look at the page well back
I downloaded the csd look at this in
2015 so  don't look at the code
because it's a completely
horrible thing 2015 look at pandas version 16
that opts for the thirty-something now I do
send record be these before but
it works the case well here it was I
have made it temporary basically
in a can set one download it and  I had that, I
had the month, the day, the time, the
toll station and the number of steps and
cars that  they went through that toll so
nothing good read it with the law with company
das and says our formations are in
the columns that I say is thinking about the
practice sign engine the Indian wanna
be who signed I put the model to
train compassion learning good blah
blah blah  blah blah but notice that I want to
show you in the third in the third is
an annual graph of the time series of
the cars that pass here you don't see much
in the middle and on the surface when
I start to go a little deeper in the
month of June  Look, they are time series
with super super super
regulars that, when studying and
testing bayern algorithms at an
extremely interesting rate, seem to me much
more interesting than the attacks that have been
going around
the bibliography and this one, for example, a
weekly detail if these are  two
physical toll stations like the
peaks when people go out in the
morning people return home at night
but have differences between Sunday and
Saturday  do that the peaks are less traffic
and the days of the week are the traffic
brothers I started well this one for this one
per day then I started trying
different techniques the objective here is not to
show the technique in particular but
rather as an open detail it
allowed me to  I began to try and play
with the things that I was learning
precisely at this conference at this
time, well here, for example, I had
done a simple one for the occasion but the
model that is green was not
treating me well on weekends in a
differentiation table  see what happens if
I put it as fitur take this it is a
weekend from the course and as fitur
it was a weekend I trained a
little further down here with determination to the
building and look how the algorithm
well began to play better well we don't
see  the idea of ​​talking about time series
but rather that there is a
very interesting process that
you can use to work
with
publicly available time series.  ic and open and not
only this, perhaps if you achieve
a good algorithm after making a
small application mobile application to
predict how much the toll is going to be at the
time it arrives is to put a little bit and the
weather progresses it affects it is interesting
this is a little bit  more more complex but
there is a portal in Argentina and for
clear prices I don't know if you know about it but
basically the government signed an
agreement with all the supermarkets
in Argentina in which the
merchants gave them the
database of their prices and their products
I think  If I remember twice a
day, then there is a website
where for two years the prices of
absolutely all the products on the
gondola of I don't know how many cents of
supermarkets in Argentina have been found, which is a
gold mine for economists who are
working on this topic
It is not open data, we are there
fighting to open it, but well,
what we did was grab and
make an escape because  ue this has an
api behind it so we did that as
a teacher but with an api that we
hit practically every month
every month we had a snapshot of
the database 16 times we already said
well this was in October of last year
two years ago  years and we didn't say well that
we want to see what the
inflationary boom is like that is happening with the
evaluations so nothing once
we had the pleasure
well there we have the attacks we clean
a little bit but look with 45 cells of
d
of pandas we begin to have information
like  For example, look here we had
the prices for September, as was the
variation in prices between September and
October 2018 in different
supermarkets if an inflation of 6% 8%
this was in the devaluation in which the
dollar went twenty-something 30
percent  so of course this is a
project that the extra per cost a
little more but they still had the
data I felt one morning drinking
mate on Saturday and when I ma  I sent a
journalist friend to this information that
the last 1900 where you got the data
nothing because we have all this
information here that all the other
project is a gold mine well they
called me a radio report blah blah but
I say nothing with an afternoon of math generates
information  extremely interesting that
he fixes it again I repeat but
certain actors in society we
can do such simple and
basic things to solve such
complex problems for others that I find
extremely interesting that
these things are shown and that they talk later
when we mix  that
database with a press database of
companies that we had that the
distribution of price increases
at that time is something of some
players
we did a cross with a database of
prices that we had here the
axis of the sixth is wrong  mind not looking a year
but think we can analyze as brands
I don't know if last night colgate is leaving he
is liking it a little  ute with the
prices luckily it is governed I mean
the different
different brand cleaning the
flour brands and look for example at a
time when a flour brand is with a
promotion and the others increase more
then here you can say why here
I do not state  method 10% and your
competition increasing two percent of
less expression are super
valid questions to ask that can be done with
four lines of bands and well a
little bit of scripting but the analysis
comes out of four lines of pandas and not
only that but  furthermore, when they
began to publish these data, they
called me from buenos aires from the center for
studies of argentine economic policy
at the cepa center and a boy, my son,
for everything he is doing
practically I only do hands and
every month I came here I have a character
of  70 products that we choose
manually perform an excel ago the change
you cannot make me an application so that
I can do it manually  nte flash of
css bus trap gave to do this again
one afternoon of work it does not need to be
aesthetic it does not need to be important the
chat did not need to automatically take
something out I did it two days
but
then of course you have gone to see
it it works I do not know if it seems to me  that we have to
start becoming aware that
we know that they are super
useful for everyone and that we have
to start using them,
well, another example that we have is
electoral data, there is also a lot of
information about justice
in elections, so with electoral data as
well  we did something
extremely interesting
well this is published in
open data format that we made one for the
santa fe team look at it
directly we hit the site of
the santa fe team they brought us a yes
we took it out like that go damme pandas and we
started doing a little  a lot of good analysis
in this notebook the only thing we did
was obviously then cases here the
only thing we are  s were a couple of
projections to test some
super basic projection algorithms
but if in this other one here it is extremely
interesting because this was for
the 2015 elections that traveled
we also downloaded all the elections of
the 2015 passage we also did the analysis
nothing is  playing but in the middle of the
day I came to a fairly
simple conclusion that it was because I remember that
after those elections of those
steps a facebook campaign began to be put together
on twitter about not watching this
telegram because it was just in the
context in which  which they put together that
application so that one enters and checks
their telegram from their table to
validate that they become in charge and the
data from the social networks started
a technical campaign saying
did you look at the telegram it has 250 votes and here
the system did not load any of them, which
was  true but they stole my election they
stole the election so I said I don't
know that it shouldn't be like that then good
analyzing a p  Oquito I came to the
conclusion that the number of tables
where the front for victory had
gotten zero votes was three thousand 900
where we change to cooking vote in 3,700
where I launched one than the rest at that
time to those 4,000 so there I called
a friend who  journalist and if you look at
this effective campaign that having in the
social is a lie because because there are
4,000 tables for each one then it is not
that there is in the re-election because the error
is distributed normally for all
then look again as with an
afternoon drinking mate and  Analyzing
electoral data, one can have the ability
to disarm a campaign on social networks
and all using
open data available to the public.
Well, another promotes this addiction or on
the official guideline. Basically, it is the money
that the state gives to the media.
in matters
of advertising we went down we did
an analysis on the national government and
well when we went to the
municipal government  when we made the municipality
we chose to look at the nation is publishing
the data on the official guideline you can
give me a voice as a municipality the money
it gives to the media in advertising they did
not tell me that
I am not really going to give you public information but they
put me  a whole lot of esoteric talk about
why they couldn't give it to me so I
said I don't care I talked to a couple of
lawyers only now they told me whether
to sue the municipality I said don't
embitter their trial because I don't want to
get into so much trouble but well we're
a lot of noise and until the
deliberative council listened to me, then the
deliberative council asked the
municipality to pay
attention to me and to hand over the province, not to me, but to them,
so I say nothing, one
can make a little noise and generate
changes another extremely interesting thing
that analyzing a little bit of data and
extracting things by making a little
noise can have an impact on
society and emp  Trying to commit the
other way is funny because they cite
the blog as the foundation but it works
with electoral rolls also once
a party called us a mendiolaza they hadn't acted
like me I already have my
electoral roll but I don't know what to do with that
it seems to me that it can be done  do a lot
of good things it
was a pdf we brought all
the information on the electoral plan and
well we discovered that for example there was
a remiseria where 46
people who had the possibility to
vote and a lot of people had registered, but obviously they
were not from Villa Allende so
obviously where they called we did
we did a little bit of a scandal
but it didn't work out and then based on that
and based on that experience with one of
the journalists from open data córdoba that
connects that connects in English
journalism network for Latin America they did
no investigation I'm not leaving  to
attribute the investigation because they
did it but well they did
an investigation on how  or there is
a voter factory operating in Argentina
in which we basically help by
extracting data from the
electoral rolls and providing them with
information and not only that, but we also
extracted data from the
Argentine Malvinas and various surrounding cities,
so we were able to identify
how voters are migrating from one
city ​​to another because the document number
appeared in the 2012 elections, not the
city in the 2015 election another city and
well now there is the whole ecological issue
this was a problem because
malvina argentinas had won the
party it was in favor of
installing the monsanto plant  So, well,
again, they gave us three registers
that are three pdfs, with tables where
we brought data, we crossed it
in four days and we had the data on
how the voters had migrated, that
later they did all the
journalistic investigation that when they and the
founder healed me, but from  back our
work and our contribution was a little  or
but the impact it had was a lot of
marine charts the last example
the marine chart for those who do not know is
basically a horrible description in
pdf of the circuits that is to say the
voting tables
then a list of in a huge pdf
of about 80 pages for the province  from
córdoba and he says well circuit one
has a table between the school with
so many voters another table with another
school with so many voters another table that
this is all the schools with their
voters so we said that
here there are two extremely
interesting things to do in the  The first is
that as in the national censuses in
which we count the population, they
are every ten years,
we do not know what, but ten years to
know how the population grows in a
place, as the elections are every two
years, I only have updated information
on the voters every  two years that
can't be it
can be that using
voter information we can develop a
trend like for that  estimating the
growth of the population of an area
I have to wait 10 years is for
the first and the second was the
political analysis of well how the
voters grow in each of the parties
then well having the 2003 marine chart
of the chart  Madrid in 2015 and
we were able to do a traceability and be able to
identify which were the
departments of the cities that
had grown the most in demographics, which
is an interesting counter analysis for them to be in politics
to make
information of good value before the
salt newspaper did the  voice but they
cite us in the article for being the ones
who started this process and
generated the data for the information
well this a little with the projects
that we did the reality is to
tell a little about other projects that
exist worldwide in which I  I
am not involved because they seem
extremely interesting to me and when with all
this with the aim of also
that you kind of be  open your mind
but I say look you give me things that can be
done you can leave here with ideas friend
what happened before you came here was
cool but I don't know how to apply this
well I hope this inspired you
to say look I can work on these
little things
the  first to speak because we always
talk about open data we talk about
public data for the reason that it is
public
but what about companies perhaps
companies could not open their data to
make open data and you can not only
use that information good for you
in an Argentine rental company
with a long history throughout Latin America
incredible things with data always
conventions and talks on any
television charges commissions
well he recently did an analysis
for the last elections on how
the price of rentals in the areas
is achieved how to predict
the vote and not only that but the age
of the voters
an extremely interesting analysis
seems worthy to me and  part congratulate him
publicly because the wta that the things
they do with data is incredible
control tower a project that I
loved that is a
research process with open data in
which he did it in an NGO in Mexico
in which the government  Previous I think it
was that of his grandson, he had an iconic project,
which was the Mexico City airport,
which was a $2
billion project, so using
open data, the guys grabbed and took out
all the tenders and all the
companies through the tenders and
they put together a whole map and a graph to see
how the tenders are distributed in
the companies and try to detect
who was getting
the silver cake if they were businesses and I don't
play the business but rather an
extremely interesting research product
with a company  person an ngo
called open contracting that what they are
trying to do is come up with a standard
for how open c data should be published
ontrataciones that is something
that I am going to talk about in
o penas pendin is another portal in which they
basically try to gather all the
data on government spending in
one place so that you cannot start
to cross-check when berlin spends its
money as it is  in London city of its
money and how Buenos Aires spends its
money and start making comparisons
based on how the governments spend the
money they have
and a project that I am going
to close with this one called friction and it gives them
what  I found it quite interesting
in its concept and basically the problem
that those of us who work in
open data have is that there is no standard
republication
buenos aires- he says well I am going to publish
my data on how he spent the money and
córdoba he says well me too but one of
us  released in one format and another book
in another format, then the time that
those of us who work
with open data have to spend to extract the data
and take it to an insight is like a
little bigger than a company
because we have to get from multiple
sources that are completely different
there are no standards we don't know what we are
going to find and although all the
information is there I have to make a
tl pipeline for each open data portal
because each  one publishes as
one wishes, so basically
what frictions data tries to do is
generate containers for data and
basically its objective is to do to the
world of data what 2 care did to the
world of applications without trying to
generate some form in the  which the
data can be contain hoisted and
cleaned so that on the other side
someone grabs them to
read and publish and analyze more
easily basically they define in
python a structure called legs that
consists of
the data is that basically one in a
jason called is packers that there are  to
write the metadata that is to say what
columns to and what type of data there is
how much data there should be etcetera
etcetera what  format should be the
date and a folder in which the
two data are and then basically what
should be the objective is the government
internally carry out an été l that
generates this for you a place where
I have a folder inside with the data and a
data  for what is there today there are that he
explains the metadata to me something that later I
compay ton quietly can be
good he imported this agreement I read the cip is
defined the sign is being read I am
reading
a csb but rather a yep and in that one I do
extract the data  that is in the
folder I extract the metadata and I can
load it in a data structure
called the cas cover that has, for example,
a valid function and that I just spoke about
in two talks today about the
importance of validating
the  data in any pipeline that
we do, so it's good to be able to have it
here, we have the meta data and how
the data that comes in there should be, to have a
function that allows us to validate
and internal  You can actually see what data you
have and you can access the data, but of
course, not only do we not
like this form very much, not only do we like
pandas, but from the pandas home page, it
can be easily exported, it can be read
directly in the data frame because the
data is there and  it is in a csb so
friction data seems to me to be an
extremely interesting process because if we manage to
unify the way in which governments
publish data it would be much easier to
consume it and extract value from it
and it has a huge ecosystem
of tools through that and
even one of the tools is cut
tables that but tables takes advantage of the
definition of the metadata that is
inside to generate an
automatic validation and they are even generating an
application that what a continuous does
is data validation as a service so
basically well I define the data  What
I want to transmit is what to do and
they automatically validate me, so
I commit it between my pip  eline the eldest and
the things developed in python and if
you look to the right
there is one for power by so they tell
nacho that he is invited to collaborate
well nothing is enough borage a little
conclusions about the talk python is
at the heart of success  open data system
and as I mentioned the main
open data publishing platform in the world is made in python
it is not data science nor in the data itself it
is pure flash and web development but
well it is made in python and therefore
we are in a position  like cool to
enter and start contributing
and also the world of open data is
an underexploited field and with a lot of
potential and when they tell me what is
exploited it is really exploited and
there is a lot of potential that even
some problems that the
governments themselves have had the governments  They themselves
are spending a lot of money to release
data, on the other hand, citizens do not
use it, so why do they release
it?  We have to use them
and make use of them so that
governments are publishing and really a
lot of valuable information not only
for the industry and to get
added value and money, but for the academy
so I want to speak a talk I don't know
where to get sample data I have to
speaking to a class, well, open portals are
used for that, so
any experience they have in
approaching and telling, I love
listening to them, and lastly, those who always
stressed that it is not necessary to make great
efforts to generate
concrete solutions to real problems because
outside of our technological niche there are
people who are far behind in the
technological context who do not have access to
us, basically because of market logic,
we have good salaries, the programmers
and because of the media, NGOs do not
have a plant to pay us, but
well, we have to find some way
as a community to get closer to  those
spaces and try
nothing else thank you very much
[Applause]
b  Good afternoon, first of all,
thank you very much for the talk and one question that
keeps me wondering is how
flexible is the type of information that
one can request from the government based on
open data. I am not an expert in the
law itself, I know that  there are certain
limitations based on what
success is, unless the person's personal information
is public officials,
then you can ask for
affidavits and expenses and
per diem, and there are some issues that,
due to national security, are
going to be denied  they don't have them but
basically whatever you can think of about
how a ministry works I don't know for example
what this is called
Marcos Peña's secretary of better the
function he has per he has a
secretary basically you can tell
them what information they take you to  they ask
what questions they ask you there is a
deliberate detail about the questions that
people ask marcos peña who later
accompanied me and answers  in the congress
then the people of a very
interesting process by the people of that
secretariat and its machine
learning algorithm for self-classification because
basically that secretariat received 700
questions and they divide it into monay you
go to the ministry of economy it was
separated to the state party  I really
made a classifier so that
when this question has to
give data automatically they labeled
all the questions but here to
answer the question everything except
personal information and something that they
would say has not been done because of the
defense or national security version I do not  I
am going to deliver it
if the question is how does the
government react to the community when it
tries to publish open data for something
that I am very close to the last part is
that it is trying to implement a
model of how to publish data so that
it works  since the
governments do it obviously there is a long way
it is not that they are suddenly going to format
t  all your data if one as a community
must lópez grab format that data you
try to share if you can not
share the government no the last
frictions data from their latest project is
basically an attempt by the ope no les
foundation to generate a tool
so that the  It is
easier for the government to publish under a standard
that later external parties can consume more
basically yes then
with that objective but to answer with
another question such as if governments resist
publishing it that it not be
published once the government
publishes it  this is in the public domain, you
can do whatever you want with it,
obviously it is always
political, always another political question
of whether the government wants to free it, as
is happening through the municipality, or that they
free him on purpose,
everyone here remembers when the
municipal plant was freed with salaries  of the
municipal that this release of data
was in a political context in which
it was pe  reading with the municipality
then always in political control in
general within the discussion within
the context of open data and the
community to all this we know that many
times they use marketing as a marketing strategy
as a political commitment
to sell the issue of transparency
but still the government  is that
finally they believe that this adds value and a
lot and that is really how they
do it, for example because they are an oven in
Chile in which they published open data
on electricity consumption and
that allowed the government that
all companies have access to how
consumes and how the electrical energy network is distributed
and that achieved that
the bidding prices of
the companies that provide services to the
state were lowered by 10 percent, so the
government, by releasing data, the companies
were able to make their bidding process more efficient
and  cost estimation
and achieve low average percent
no sensitive data free
ar another thesis in a fight but
well here we are in the fight
very good talk a comment and a
question we for the two guys
who asked before we did from
having a national movement of
recovered companies a request for
public information asking for information about the
loan that  the government made at the end of
57 billion dollars the
optimal response of the justice of the ministry
of finance and the central bank is that
there is neither ruling nor any
administrative act that says how
lost money is lent piece forgiveness
a signature  a rent and there is a contract
but for asking for 57 billion dollars
it is not that I get into politics but
that is exactly what I was going for, it is in the most
important issues in my experience it is difficult to
obtain data as there is already a voice in
marketing matters where it
suits them  they release on more
serious important issues like a lot of
later there is no information and he
asks me how to ma  normally you deny that
with lawyers or two you
have some team because our
experience has been very technical and many
times we lacked that a more
political hand d
but in the cordoba blog because we
faced problems we spoke with
a group of lawyers to see what
we can do and there on the blog we put
all the things that one can do in
case the government denies the
information action but basically
there is an NGO and citizen power that
works a lot advising itself and they
are not in Córdoba so the mail
is  fundep, which is an organization that
also works with transparency, that
has a group of lawyers and that
can give you a hand, so there is nothing
more to do than get legal means in Buenos
Aires, the city of Buenos Aires does not publish
the data of the official guideline and a
boy made a demand that went to the
second instance of the supreme court
for the data to enter, handing over to
Peruvian in those sensitive cases  all you have to do
is put your citizenship on your
shoulder and contact a lawyer
[Music]